la séance est reprise et l'ordre du jour
appelle
la discussion de la proposition de loi
que de concernant les couples confrontés
à une fausse couche et dans la décision
générale la parole est d'abord à la
ministre Isabelle Rome
madame la Présidente Charles Laurent
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le terme de fausse couche ravive souvent
des blessures anciennes récentes ou
encore l'angoisse d'un futur meurtri et
c'est à force de politique publique
ambitieuse que nous aiderons les femmes
à traverser cette épreuve avec la
première ministre Elisabeth borne et mon
collègue François Brown nous avons fait
de la santé des femmes l'une des
priorités du plan égalité 2027 nous
avons souhaité briser les tabous qui
trop souvent pénalise les femmes dans
leur vie quotidienne professionnelles et
personnelles le tabou des règles par
exemple mais également celui des fausses
couches la proposition de loi que vous
vous apprêtez à examiner aujourd'hui et
j'en suis convaincu dans la droite ligne
de tous ces progrès
je souligne le travail de la députée
Josso pour aboutir aux articles
ambitieux de ce texte
parce que nous avons conscience de
l'urgence que constitue ses avancées le
gouvernement a engagé la procédure
accélérée sur ce texte le 6 mars dernier
comme un symbole cette proposition de
loi a été votée à l'Assemblée nationale
à l'unanimité dans la nuit du 8 mars ce
vote transpartisan a été exemplaire une
nouvelle fois il a prouvé que nous
étions capables de nous unir pour les
droits et la santé des femmes
c'est le proposition de loi contient
trois articles destinés à renforcer
l'accompagnement et la formation de
celles et ceux qui sont confrontés à
l'épreuve d'une fausse couche et à mieux
former et sensibiliser les
professionnels de santé à ses enjeux
elle porte avec force l'enjeu qu'il y a
à améliorer l'accompagnement
pluridisciplinaire des femmes victimes
de fausses couches
d'ici le premier septembre 2024 un
parcours interruption spontanée de
grossesse sera mise en place par chaque
agence régionale de santé ces parcours
associéont les médecins les sages-femmes
et les psychologues
il s'agira à la fois de renforcer
l'accompagnement psychologique et
médical des patients et de leur
partenaire afin d'alléger au maximum les
souffrances psychologiques liées à cette
épreuve et de mieux comprendre et
traiter les éventuels causes médicales
de ces événements
nous renforcerons également la formation
des professionnels de santé impliquées
dans ces parcours
les patientes et leur partenaire si
elles sont en couple seront ainsi mieux
informés et écoutés elles pourront
exprimer librement leur souffrance et se
voir proposer des solutions adaptées
cette proposition de loi met également
en oeuvre plusieurs mesures prévues dans
le plan toutes et toutes égaux que j'ai
présenté le 8 mars en conseil des
ministres et qui engage l'action du
gouvernement en matière d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes jusqu'en 2027
le gouvernement a amendé cette
proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
nationale en supprimant le délai de
carence en cas d'arrêt maladie lié à une
fausse couche il s'agit d'une avancée
majeure qui permettra aux femmes de ne
plus être pénalisés financièrement après
une fausse couche tout en préservant
vis-à-vis de leur employeur une pleine
confidentialité ce qui est très
important
vous avez monsieur le rapporteur lévrier
proposé un amendement tout à fait
bienvenue en commission afin d'étendre
cette disposition aux indépendantes et à
leur conjoint
le gouvernement proposera en séance un
amendement prévoyant la même extension
pour les non salariés agricoles
les sages-femmes pourront également
proposer à leur patiente d'être prise en
charge par un psychologue conventionné
dans le cadre du dispositif mon parcours
psy cela sera aussi le cas pour les
partenaires de celles qui subissent une
fausse couche
cette prise en charge psychologique est
essentielle tant les traumatismes liés à
ces drames se réveille parfois tard et
nécessite une prise en charge sur le
long terme
il s'agit aussi et j'aimerais le
souligner d'une vraie reconnaissance du
travail effectuée quotidiennement par
les sages-femmes auxquelles je sais que
les parlementaires des deux chambres
sont attachées et je peux moi aussi
témoigner du travail qu'elle mène au
quotidien sur l'ensemble des territoires
la prise en compte de ces mesures par le
vote de nos amendements gouvernementaux
ou les avancées adoptées en commission
des affaires sociales sont un symbole
fort dont la manière dont le pouvoir
exécutif et le pouvoir législatif
travail ensemble sur nos grands enjeux
de société ce sont des progrès comme
celui-ci qui font de nous le pays des
grandes avancées sociales mais aussi le
pays des droits de l'homme comme celui
des droits des femmes
vous l'aurez compris vous tenez entre
vos mains un objet législatif essentiel
à la vie de nombreuses femmes qui
j'espère sera adopté le plus largement
sur ses bancs je vous remercie
merci la parole sera ensuite au rapport
de la commission des affaires sociales
Monsieur Martin lévrier
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues chaque année 200000 françaises
sont confrontés à l'interruption
spontanée de leur grossesse avant la 2e
semaine d'aménorrhée
si pour les femmes concernées et leur
partenaire éventuels il existe autant de
vécus possible que de fausses couches
une interruption spontanée de grossesse
génère de l'anxiété ou des symptômes
dépressifs chez plus du tiers des
personnes qui la traversent après une
fausse couche tous les couples ne
nécessitent donc pas d'assistance
spécifique insistons sur ce point mais
pour ceux qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement complémentaire visé par
cette proposition de loi les dispositifs
de soutien apparaissent insuffisamment
nombreux et effectifs faute parfois
d'information adéquate
cela témoigne du tabou qui entoure la
fausse couche encore souvent perçue
comme un non événement arrivant
majoritairement dans un premier
trimestre silencieux un stade où la
grossesse n'est en général pas dévoilé
combien parmi nous serait précisément
définir une fausse couche et en exposer
les cours les causes principales la
méconnaissance de ce phénomène
transparaît jusque dans le vocabulaire
employé pour le qualifier l'expression
faire une fausse couche qui semble
rendre la femme enceinte actrice voire
responsable de la perte de sa grossesse
apparaît à cet égard particulièrement
malheureuse alors même que la plupart
des fausses couches sont d'originalité
naturelle et découlent d'anomalies
génétiques de l'embryon le rendant non
viable
d'autres termes pourraient lui être
préféré j'y reviendrai la proposition de
loi que nous examinons ce matin a été
déposé par la députée Sandrine Josso
dont je salue la présence parmi nous et
adopter à l'unanimité à l'Assemblée
nationale
les trois articles qu'elle contient
entendre renforcer l'accompagnement et
la formation des couples confrontés à
une interruption spontanée de grossesse
l'article premier prévoit la mise en
place par les agences régionales de
santé et d'ici au 1er septembre 2024
d'un parcours spécifique associant
médecin sage-femme et psychologue dans
la prise en charge des interruptions
spontanées de grossesse celui-ci doit
permettre d'améliorer l'information et
le suivi médical comme psychologique des
patientes et de leurs partenaires
éventuels ainsi que de renforcer la
formation des professionnels de santé
impliqués
la Commission a soutenu sa disposition
susceptibles de favoriser une meilleure
organisation des professionnels médicaux
dans chaque territoire et de mieux tenir
compte du besoin d'accompagnement
psychologique de certains couples
victimes d'une interruption spontanée de
grossesse
elle a toutefois adopté deux amendements
le premier renforce les objectifs
d'information des parcours en précisant
que ceci devront viser à systématiser
l'information des patients et de leur
partenaire sur le phénomène
d'interruption spontanée de grossesse
les possibilités de traitement ou
d'intervention et les dispositifs de
suivi et d'accompagnement disponibles le
second a renommé le parcours pour
préférer à l'expression fausse couche
jugée stigmatisante et négative par les
associations celle d'interruption
spontanée de grossesse plus neutre et
plus juste médicalement la Commission a
apporté la même modification à
l'intitulé de la proposition de loi
l'article 1 B ajouté ajouté par
amendement gouvernemental en séance à
l'Assemblée lève le délai de carence
applicable à l'indemnisation des congés
malades pris consécutivement à une
interruption spontanée de grossesse
aujourd'hui une assurée du régime
général confronté à une fausse couche et
dont l'état de santé nécessite un arrêt
de travail n'est indemnisé par la
Sécurité Sociale qu'a compté du
quatrième jour lorsque l'arrêt maladie
se fait au prix du renoncement à 10% de
son salaire mensuel il devient un luxe
que toutes ne peuvent se permettre
pour celles qui ne peuvent se l'accorder
en outre exposés à des situations
professionnelles parfois embarrassantes
dérangeantes ou stressantes les
perspectives de reconstruction saine
peuvent être gravées en permettant comme
à la suite d'une morphe fatale in utero
une indemnisation dès le premier jour
d'arrêt le dispositif dessert les
contraintes financières s'opposant au
recours à l'arrêt de travail tout en ne
nécessitant pas ma formation de
l'employeur quant à ces motifs
contrairement à un congé pour événement
familial Haddock il n'expose donc les
bénéficiaires à aucun risque de
discrimination
pour atteindre pleinement son objectif
le dispositif plébiscité lors de
l'assemblée des auditions l'ensemble des
auditions que j'ai conduites doit être
universalisée initialement restreint aux
fonctionnaires et aux assurés des
régimes générales spéciaux et assimilés
sont bénéfice a été élargi aux
indépendantes en commission à mon
initiative faute de recevabilité
financière je n'ai pas pu en faire de
même avec les non salariés agricoles
dernier régime à ne pas être couvert il
est clair que ce progrès doit être
équitable et concerné l'ensemble des
assurés je vous ai donc appelé madame la
ministre à amender le texte en ce sens
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
l'article premier vise à permettre au
sage-femmes d'adresser un psychologue
conventionné dans le cadre de dispositif
mon parcours psy leur patiente et dans
les cas d'interruption spontanée de
grossesse leur partenaire
la Commission a souscrit à l'objectif
poursuivi par ces dispositions qui
permettront au couple concerné de
bénéficier plus largement qu'aujourd'hui
de séances de suivi psychologique prise
en charge prise en charge par
l'Assurance Maladie toutefois elle a
observé que le dispositif mon parcours
si lancé en avril 2022 peine encore à se
déployer et ne permettra pas dans ces
conditions de répondre aux besoins
constatés moins de 10% des psychologues
concernés libéraux salariés d'un centre
de santé participent aujourd'hui au
dispositif et moins de 80000 patients en
ont bénéficié en 2022 la tarification et
la durée limitée des séances prises en
charge sont mises en avant par les
psychologues en facteurs explicatifs
c'est pourquoi il apparaît indispensable
qu'une évaluation des dispositifs soit
rapidement conduite afin d'identifier
les moyens d'encourager la participation
des psychologues et de faire bénéficier
du dispositif les patients en ayant le
plus besoin et nous savons madame la
ministre que vous appelez à cette tâche
les articles 1 bis et inter adopté en
séance l'Assemblée nationale contre la
vie du gouvernement et de la Commission
ont été supprimés à mon initiative le
premier faisait obligation
professionnelle de santé impliqué dans
la prise en charge des interruption
spontanées de grossesse d'informer leur
patients des possibilités de traitement
et de leur implication et de leur
proposer un nouvel examen médical 4
semaines après le premier
parce qu'elles sont déjà largement
satisfaites par le droit à l'information
des malades consacré depuis 2002 et
contraignent inutilement l'exercice des
professionnels de santé d'ores et déjà
encadrés par des règles déontologiques
et les recommandations des sociétés
savantes ces dispo ces dispositions sont
apparues inopportunes à la Commission
le second article consistait ennuie de
demande de rapport sur l'extension de
l'assurance maternité dès les premières
semaines d'aménorrhée ce qui aurait
engendré une complexité opérationnelle
considérable pour la sécurité sociale
tous en présentant un caractère
dispendieux enfin je vous proposerai au
nom de la commission de mieux protéger
les femmes victimes d'une interruption
spontanée de grossesse du risque de
discrimination professionnelle en
adoptant une interdiction de
licenciement de 10 semaines à l'écart
des femmes confrontées et interruption
spontanée de grossesse dite tardive
après la quatrième semaine d'aménorrhée
dans ces cas qui concerne moins de 1%
des grossesses et concentre les risques
de discrimination les salariés concernés
de bénéficient d'aucune protection
contre licenciement la différence de
traitement avec les femmes qui perdent
leur grossesse après la 22e Semaine qui
dispose d'une protection contre
licenciement de 26 semaines minimum
apparaît à cet égard disproportionné il
nous appartient mes chers collègues de
corriger cela
mes chers collègues cette proposition de
loi améliorée par les travaux de la
commission et complété par les
dispositions que nous vous proposons
nous que nous proposerons d'adopter
constitue une véritable avancée pour les
femmes confrontées et une interruption
Spontin de grossesse et leur partenaires
en ascension davantage professionnel de
santé et psychologue pour un
accompagnement pluridisciplinaire en
garantissant une meilleure prise en
charge des interruptions de travail et
des séances de suivi psychologiques elle
permettra de mieux tenir compte des
conséquences psychologiques potentielles
des interruptions spontanées de
grossesse
beaucoup restera à faire par la suite
dans ces domaines qui ne relevait pas de
ce texte je souhaite que le gouvernement
puisse prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent pour renforcer la formation
initiale et continue des professionnels
de santé à la prise en charge et à
l'accompagnement notamment psychologique
des femmes confrontées une interruption
spontanée de grossesse et je sais madame
la ministre pouvoir compter sur votre
engagement
je crois également qu'il serait utile
que les élèves au cours de leur parcours
scolaire soit davantage sensibilisés aux
causes biologiques des interruptions
spontanées de grossesse alors
conséquence physique et psychiques enfin
chaque patiente concernait devrait
recevoir un support écrit récapitulant
les informations essentielles dont elle
a besoin c'est assez conditions que nous
parviendrons à briser l'isolement des
couples confrontés et interruption
spontanée de grossesse cette loi y
contribue c'est pourquoi je vous invite
à lui accorder la vaste majorité qu'elle
mérite je vous remercie
merci dans la discussion générale la
parole va être maintenant Madame
Véronique Guillotin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique sociale
européen
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de commission
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
cette proposition de loi s'intéresse à
un sujet qui touche une femme sur dix
tout en étant presque tabou et qui
touche à un événement
dont une grossesse sur quatre l'an
dernier tout en étant très peu pris en
charge le conseil est partagé la fausse
couche a été trop longtemps minimiser et
l'accompagnement des couples doit être
renforcée ce constat s'appuie notamment
sur une étude du Lancet qui décrit le
silence et le manque d'empathie autour
des fausses couches et qui demande que
les femmes soient mieux prises en charge
sur le plan médical mais aussi et
surtout sur le plan psychologique en
effet la respontanée d'une grossesse
peut être vécue comme un événement
traumatique et au-delà des douleurs et
des éventuels complications médicales on
constate chez certains couples une
véritable souffrance liée au deuil d'une
parentalité dans lequel dans laquelle il
s'était déjà projeté
le taux d'anxiété de dépression a été
mesuré et il est d'ailleurs plus élevé
chez les femmes et leur partenaires
après un tel événement plus qu'une
insuffisance de prise en charge le
professeur Friedman parle de véritable
vide juridiques cette proposition de loi
propose un parcours d'accompagnement
médical et psychologique des femmes et
de leur partenaire compte tenu de leur
implication croissante dans les
grossesses des femmes et dans l'arrivée
du bébé ce que l'on peut que saluer
cette mesure intégrée lors de l'examen
du texte à l'Assemblée nationale nous
paraît pertinente l'autre mesure
essentielle de cette proposition de loi
a été permise par le gouvernement dont
nous saluons l'initiative en effet le
délai de carence pour les arrêts de
travail liés à une interruption
spontanée de grossesse sera ainsi
supprimée nous saluons le travail
conjoint du rapporteur et du
gouvernement qui devrait permettre sous
réserve d'adoption de l'amendement de
faire bénéficier de cette mesure à
toutes les femmes quel que soit leur
statut professionnel c'est une question
d'équité et de justice
s'agissant du débat autour de la mise à
disposition par certaines entreprises de
jours de congés en cas de fausse couche
la vie de notre groupe émitigé si la
mesure paraît certes intéressante nous
craignons qu'on incite en incitant pas
la patiente à consulter la mesure
éloigne le couple d'un parcours de soins
dont il aurait besoin et s'éloigne aussi
de l'esprit du texte l'évaluation des
expérimentations qui débutent permettra
peut-être de lever ses doutes
concernant la possibilité pour les
sages-femmes d'adresser des patients au
parcours au dispositif mon parcours psy
avec à la clé le remboursement de 8
séances chez un psy conventionnées la
mesure va évidemment dans le bon sens
mais le faible déploiement du dispositif
fait douter de son efficience et ne
permettra probablement pas de répondre à
tous les besoins en effet à ce jour - de
10% des psychologues en libéral ou en
exercice mixte y participent je sais que
le Sénat n'est pas favorable aux
demandes de rapport vaste débat pendant
la commission mais il est
particulièrement justifié d'évaluer mon
parcours psy et de le corriger si besoin
notamment parce que la proposition de
loi repose en grande partie sur
l'efficacité de ce dispositif je
défendrai donc comme ma collègue Annie
Bilon un amendement visant à inclure
dans le rapport prévu l'an prochain sur
mon parcours si une évaluation de
l'accessibilité du dispositif pour les
couples confrontés à une fausse couche
pour finir madame la mini je tenais à
insister sur le volet de la prévention
si plus le plus souvent les fausses
couches sont consécutives à des
anomalies génétiques de l'embryon
certains facteurs individuels sont
associés à une augmentation du risque
l'âge des patientes par exemple ou des
parents un IMC très bas ou au contraire
un IMC très élevé l'alcool le tabac le
stress le travail de nuit ou encore
l'exposition aux pesticides la stratégie
nationale de santé sexuelle 2027 2030
inclut la prévention de l'infertilité
mais on peut regretter que les fausses
couches en regardant bien ne fassent pas
l'objet d'une mention particulière nous
avons par ailleurs voté dans le PLFSS
pour 2023 la mise en place de
rendez-vous de prévention à des âges
clés de la vie qui pourraient être à ce
moment-là une excellente occasion
d'aborder le sujet auprès des personnes
en âge de procréer avec toutes ces
remarques le groupe RDS votera en faveur
de cette proposition de loi
[Applaudissements]
si la parole est maintenant à Laurent
Burgoa pour le groupe républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues cette proposition de loi à le
mérite de libérer la parole autour d'un
événement aussi difficile que fréquent
pour de nombreuses femmes ce que l'on
qualifie encore de fausses couches
concernant les faits près de 15% de
grossesse et plus d'une femme sur dix y
aurait été confrontés un chiffre
important qui reste pourtant trop
souvent tabou et qui en 2023 ne devrait
plus l'être ce tabou masque souvent une
blessure mais il peut être aussi être le
marqueur d'un sentiment de culpabilité
qui n'est pas acceptable prenons alors
le temps de rappeler que ces fausses
couches sont en grande majorité
consécutives à des anomalies génétiques
de l'embryon ces dernières faisant
obstacle à la poursuite de la grossesse
la probabilité de sa survenue dépend
d'ailleurs d'une multitude de facteurs
qui peuvent par exemple être associés au
géniteur large de conception du premier
enfant étant de plus en plus élevé dans
notre société il est important de
s'emparer de ce sujet j'ai alors suivi
les auditions conduites par notre
collègue rapporteur Martin lévrier avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et je la remercie
aujourd'hui les couples confrontés un
interruption spontanée de grossesse
avant le 22e semaine d'aménorrhée ne
bénéficie d'aucun dispositif les sans
penser qu'il s'agit d'un bon événement
pourtant pour les femmes concernées il
s'agit là de saignement important de
douleur à devenir et parfois d'infection
si les conséquences restent souvent
bénignes il n'empêche que cet événement
intervienne subitement alors que la
femme qui a des victimes peut être en
train de faire une présentation être en
rendez-vous bref être en plein travail
et puis ça se renut soulève de
nombreuses questions il m'a paru
important de saluer ici l'accompagnement
accordée par certains entreprises
françaises qui offrent désormais des
congés aux femmes et ont subi une telle
interruption spontanée
c'est d'autant plus ça saluer que ces
interruptions interviennent avant les
trois premiers mois de la grossesse qui
très souvent ne sont pas encore annoncés
aux proches c'est d'ailleurs ce non dit
qui participe à l'isolement des couples
avec leur question qui reste sans
réponse c'est ce moment d'isolement qui
est le terreau fertile a des
répercussions psychologiques en effet un
mois après l'interruption spontanée de
leur grossesse 24% des femmes souffrent
d'anxiété et 11% de dépression l'article
premier a de la présidente de
proposition de loi fait obligation aux
agences régionales santé de mettre en
place un parcours force couche associant
médecin sage-femme et psychologue il
donne pour objectif de développer la
formation des professionnels et
d'améliorer le suivi psychologique et
médical des patientes et de leur
partenaire
ces dispositions ont évidemment été
accueillis favorablement commission même
si nous avons adopter deux amendements à
cet article l'un pour substituer à
l'expression de fausses couches souvent
perçue comme stigmatisante l'utilisation
du terme d'interruption spontanée de
grossesse et un deuxième pour renforcer
les objectifs d'information qui leur
sont assignés en effet il était
essentiel que toutes les femmes puissent
recevoir des renseignements complets sur
dispositif d'accompagnement disponible
l'article premier favorise également
l'accompagne en psychologie des couples
en permettant aux sages-femmes
d'adresser leur patiente à un
psychologue conventionné sur le principe
c'est une bonne chose mais disons-le le
dispositif en parcours si ton
véritablement être amélioré tant le
déficit professionnel et criant
aujourd'hui
93% de leur profession s'en boycotter ce
dispositif dont certains dénonces des
conséquences des terres sur
l'organisation des soins en santé
mentale et sa proportion à creuser
l'inégalités d'accès aux souhaits quand
à l'article premier B il supprime le
délai de carence applica aux arrêts
maladie liées à une interruption
spontanée pour les assurer du régime
général et assimilés pour les agents de
public et pour les assurer de régime
spéciaux le texte est une excellente
chose en temps desserrer les contraintes
financières pesant sur les femmes
concernées en permettant une
indemnisation dès le premier jour
d'arrêt notre collègue rapporteur a
déposé un amendement pour un étendre le
bénéfice aux indépendantes et invite le
gouvernement à faire de même pour les
non salariés récoltes enfin vous l'aurez
compris de l'élargir à toutes les
assurés sociales ce qui me semble-t-il
serait une mesure de justice que je
soutiens et je vous remercie de déposer
cet amendement enfin puisque je viens
d'évoquer un vœu de notre rapporteur
permettez-moi de pour me dire également
le mien j'ai pu rencontrer des
représentants de sages-femmes qui m’ont
interpellé sur le fait que leur
profession peut bien bien prescrire du
misoprostol dans le cas très souvent
difficile dirigé mais qu'elle ne parle
pas dans les conditions bien plus
courantes d'interruption spontanée il
doivent alors patientes vers les
urgences dont ce n'est pas le rôle et
rend ainsi leur parcours de soins plus
difficiles encore dans le cas de
l'interruption spontanée jusqu'à 9
semaines aménorrhées et puisqu'il s'agit
d'une prérogative de pouvoir
réglementaire je vous invite fortement
dans la ministre à modifier ce fameux
décret pour conclure bien que cette
proposition de loi ne règle pas toutes
les difficultés et le contiennent des
avancées qui commet de soutenir c'est ce
que le groupe les républicains fera à
l'envoltant je vous remercie
la parole est à Colette mélo pour le
groupe Les Indépendants
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
monsieur rapporteur
mes chers collègues qui ne connais pas
au moins une femme ayant été confrontée
à une fausse couche dans son entourage
plus ou moins proche pour cause cet
événement touche environ 200000 femmes
par an en France et concernent une
grossesse sur 4 les interruptions
spontanées de grossesse sont donc des
événements fréquents mais ce n'est pas
parce qu'un événement est fréquent qu'il
est banal pour la personne qui le vit
je tiens avant tout à saluer la qualité
des échanges qui se sont tenus en
commission sur un sujet aussi délicat
comme cela a été rappelé au cours de
l'examen du texte une interruption
spontanée de grossesse n'est pas
nécessairement vécu comme un traumatisme
ou une souffrance c'est un point
important qu'il est nécessaire de
rappeler ne serait-ce que pour éviter
aux femmes qui ne le vivent pas comme un
drame de ce penser insensible
certaines femmes le vivent néanmoins
comme un choc un traumatisme voire comme
la véritable perte de l'enfant dans
lequel elle s'était projetée et quand il
ne s'agit pas d'une interruption
spontanée de grossesse isolées mais de
la troisième ou de la quatrième cela
peut être vécu de façon particulièrement
difficile
chaque femme vit donc cet événement
différemment et d'une manière qui lui
est propre il doit être ni banalisé ni
dramatisé mais simplement faire l'objet
d'un accompagnement spécifique adapté à
la façon dont la femme qui est
confrontée le vide c'est ce que propose
le présente il vise à permettre aux
couples qui le vivrait comme un
traumatisme d'être mieux accompagné sur
le plan psychologique voire accompagner
tout court car s'il est un point commun
à tous les différents vécus suite une
ISG c'est le tabou dont ils sont l'objet
combien de femmes font une fausse couche
le lundi soir et retourne travailler le
mardi matin comme si de rien n'était
combien parmi celles qui le vivent comme
un drame en parle ensuite avec un
psychologue
la mise en place d'un parcours
interruption spontanée de grossesse par
chaque ARS tel que proposée par le texte
constitue une première étape
indispensable pour améliorer
l'accompagnement des femmes sur ce sujet
développer la coordination et la
formation des médecins des sages-femmes
et des psychologues ainsi que la bonne
information des femmes sur ce sujet est
un effet primordial le texte prévoit
également la possibilité pour les
sages-femmes d'adresser leur patientes
victimes du l'ISG ainsi que leur
partenaire un psychologue dans le cadre
du dispositif mon parcours psy les
sages-femmes réalisent pas toujours dans
les meilleures conditions un travail
formidable et sont au plus près des
patientes
cette mesure est une juste
reconnaissance de leur rôle fondamental
en commission c'est aussi posé la
question de la création d'un congé
spécial à la suite d'une ISG nous n'y
sommes pas favorables car cela
représenterait un risque de
stigmatisation pour les femmes en
entreprise nous pensons que la
suppression du délai de carence
dans le cadre de l'arrêt maladie faisant
ensuite à une USG comme le propose le
texte représente déjà une avancée
satisfaisante
enfin n'oublions cependant pas que
l'essentiel de ce texte reposent sur le
dispositif mon parcours psy dont
l'efficacité est discutable à cause du
manque de professionnels volontaire
il est donc essentiel de renforcer la
participation des psychologues pour que
ce dispositif soit efficace
plus largement c'est sur la santé
mentale en général dans notre pays qui
est urgent d'avancer
je voudrais avant de terminer sur le
rôle que peut
parler enfin insister sur le rôle que
peut jouer l'éducation en milieu
scolaire
l'éducation en matière
sexuelle notamment n'est pas encore
assez assez importantes pour aider
vraiment la jeunesse à se construire
et aussi sur la sensibilité à la
prévention
dans beaucoup de dans beaucoup de
domaines
en tout cas notre groupe votera bien sûr
en faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à Raymond de
bonsaimont je pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers
j'ai pleuré toutes les larmes de mon
corps pendant trois jours c'était je
détestais la planète entière en sortant
de chez le docteur tout d'un coup je me
suis effondré je vois toutes les copines
elles ont des bébés tout va bien mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de mal ce sont
les témoignages de femmes qui ont vécu
des fausses couches et qui se sont
confiées à une équipe de chercheurs et
de cerceuses autour de nathalen séjourné
parfois une fausse couche peut être
extrêmement traumatisante pour la femme
du fait de la perte certes mais aussi
parce que la fausse couche reste un non
dit de fait un tabou pourtant elles
existent bel et bien en France chaque
année 200 000 femmes vivent une fausse
couche un quart des grossesse saute
ainsi interrompu
quand ma grille se tabou on parle des
fausses couches elles sont présentées
comme des échecs des défauts peut
surprenant alors que pédophile aux en
parler même à leur famille même à leurs
amis les plus proches ce tabou étouffé
les femmes qui ont fait une fausse
couche et qui en souffrent il faut donc
améliorer l'accompagnement de ces femmes
et de leur partenaires qui en ont besoin
c'est pourquoi cette proposition de loi
est une étape importante et le groupe
écologiste en est reconnaissant elle a
député Sandrine Josso monsieur le
rapporteur merci pour votre travail qui
améliore le texte à plusieurs égards
nous apprécions que vous systématisiez
expression interruption spontanée de
grossesse et que vous souteniez
versement immédiat des indemnités
journalières le groupe écologiste
soutient bien évidemment cette
proposition et nous ne doutons pas
qu'elle trouvera un large soutien
transpartisan
mais vous gêne à qui je donne ma voix le
temps qu'elle retrouve la sienne a suivi
cette PPL et vous adresse toutefois une
question pourquoi ne permetsons nous pas
un couple de se reposer après une fausse
couche qui peut être traumatisant
pourquoi ne libérons nous pas du temps
pour un couple pour permettre le travail
du deuil imaginez que vous êtes bien sûr
projeté d'avoir un enfant puis
soudainement rien il faut que les
couples qui le souhaitent et le temps de
se poser et de se reposer d'autres pays
reconnaissent déjà ce besoin la
Nouvelle-Zélande a voté un congé spécial
de trois jours après une fausse couche
aux Philippines les femmes bénéficient
d'indemnités de maternité jusqu'à 60
jours en cas de fausse couche jusqu'à 6
semaines en Inde en France la loi ne
prévoit rien mais cela commence à
changer depuis quelques semaines les
salariés de la convention collective
Syntec peuvent demander un projet
spécial après une fausse couche à nous
de proposer ce congé pour l'ensemble des
salariés dans le droit du travail à nous
de permettre aux coupes qui en ont
besoin de se reposer quelques jours
après une interruption un interruption
spontanée de grossesse c'est pourquoi le
groupe écologiste demande d'ouvrir la
possibilité aux couples de demander un
congé spécial de trois jours trois jours
il nous semble ce n'est pas trop
demander évidemment
il n'y aurait aucune obligation de
demander ce que j'ai spécial il s'agit
d'une possibilité à la femme et à ça ou
son partenaire de décider mais ouvrir ce
choix
au couple je le précise par rapport à la
crainte d'une stigmatisation
d'autre part parce que le travail est
une charge qu'on est en deuil après une
fausse couche et d'autre part parce que
cette mesure serait une aide concrète
après une fausse couche ainsi les autres
mesures de ce texte bienvenue serait
d'autant plus efficace d'autant plus
efficient enfin il est juste il est
juste et nous en remercions que le
gouvernement est accepté de verser des
indemnités journalières dès le premier
jour pour les femmes en incapacité de
travailler après une fausse couche mais
saisissons cette occasion pour faire
encore plus reculer le tabou et le congé
spécial on fait vraiment partie
faire reculer le tabou et marquer
vraiment une grande avancée pour les
femmes
nous sautons bien évidemment ce texte
mais nous vous proposons d'aller plus
loin c'est possible et c'est nécessaire
je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à
Patricia schinger pour le groupe RDP
[Applaudissements]
à l'anglaise madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues le corps
des femmes et les sujets qui s'y
rapportent font encore trop souvent
l'objet de tabou en nous saisissant plus
particulièrement de la situation des
femmes victimes de fausses couches le
groupe RDPI moi-même ne nous régissons
que notre chambre contribue à lever l'un
de ces non-dits avant toute chose je
tiens à saluer le travail de Madame
Sandrine je saut auteur de cette
proposition de loi et à la remercier de
cette saisie de ce sujet sensible et
important
au regard du nombre des femmes
concernées se sont environ 200 000
fausses couches qui sont détectés chaque
année en France alors qu'on estime
qu'une femme sur quatre y est confronté
au moins une fois au cours de sa vie la
fréquence de ce phénomène constate avec
le peu de voir l'absence
d'accompagnement proposer à ces femmes
il faut rappeler en effet que les
interruptions spontanées de grossesse ne
sont que rarement considérés comme un
problème grave sur le plan médical
pourtant entre 20 et 55% des femmes
présentes des symptômes dépressives
auprès après une fausse couche tandis
que 15% connaissent un état de stress
prostomatique par ailleurs la douleur et
le traumatisme que peut induire ce type
d'événements ne sont pas proportionnels
à l'âge de stationnelles on peut très
tôt dans le courant de la grossesse
cette projetée en tant que parents et
s'être préparé à l'accueil d'un enfant
lorsque tout cela s'arrête brutalement
ce n'est pas de la sa grossesse dont il
faut faire le deuil mais bien de cet
enfant dont on préparait déjà la venue
s'il faut bien sûr distinguer le
ressenti de chacun dans une telle
situation il est toutefois important de
pouvoir proposer un accompagnement
psychologique adapté aux femmes et à
leur conjoint dont la santé mentale peut
être affectée par une interruption
spontanée de grossesse c'est ce que
permet cette proposition de loi en
habilitant les sages-femmes à s'adresser
à leur patiente à un psychologue dans le
cadre du dispositif mon parcours psy je
relève qu'à l'issue de son passage en
commission à l'Assemblée nationale cette
habilitation vaut désarmants pour tout
type de situation lié à la grossesse
autre apport l'extension en cas de
fausse couche de cet accompagnement au
ou à la partenaire de la patiente il
s'agit de deux améliorations qui vont
dans le bon sens et qui contribuent
d'une part à la reconnaissance de la
souffrance de ces femmes et de leur
conjoint et d'autre part contribuent
également à souligner le rôle de
première importance des sages-femmes
dans l'accompagnement de la grossesse
autre apport de l'assemblée que je tiens
à saluer la mise en place à l'horizon de
septembre 2024 par une agence régionale
de santé d'un parcours interruption
spontanée de grossesse notre rapporteur
le sénateur Martin lévrier a tenu à
renforcer les objectifs d'information et
je ne peux qu'il souscrire tant cela est
nécessaire pour répondre et prévenir le
sentiment d'isolement et
d'incompréhension on cale ses femmes et
leur partenaire font face je salue
également la suppression du délai de
carence pour l'indemnisation des arrêts
de travail consécutifs à une
interruption spontanée de grossesse
soutenu à l'Assemblée nationale par le
gouvernement son extension par notre
rapporteur aux indépendants
méritent d'être soulignés c'est un
apport impertinent avec mes collègues
sénateur RDPI nous voterons pour ce
texte porteur d'une avancée
significative en faveur du droit des
femmes au premier rang de quel celui à
la santé et me réjouit enfin du
consensus transpartisan que se dégage de
l'examen de ce texte je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame mignonne Emilienne Poumirol vous
avez la parole pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente des commissaires la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues la proposition de loi
que nous examinons aujourd'hui a pour
donc pour objectif de renforcer la prise
en charge médicale et psychologique des
femmes et le cas échéant de leur
partenaire après l'interruption
spontanée de grossesse avant la 22e
semaine d'aménorrhée
en 2021 la revision scientifique
britannique The landset publie un
rapport sur lequel environ 23 millions
de fausses couches se produisent chaque
année dans le monde soit 15% du total
des grossesse cela concerne une femme
sur 10 et en France 200 000 femmes
chaque année sont confrontés à cette ISG
le rappeur appelé à prendre sérieux les
troubles liés à une fausse couche et
recommandé que les femmes puissent
bénéficier d'un suivi minimum avec
notamment
insulter un psychologique pour le couple
et des conseils avant des grossesses
ultérieurs bien qu'elle soit dans la
majorité des cas considéré comme Benini
sur le plan médical les interruptions de
grossesse peuvent avoir des conséquences
psychologiques et psychiques importantes
chez certaines femmes et leurs
partenaire et ce même un stade précoce
de la grossesse aujourd'hui en France
cette dimension psychique reste
sous-estimée et parfois même oublier
dans la prise en charge des fausses du
coup je suppose spontanées
en effet les professionnels médicaux
prennent en charge bien sûr l'aspect
purement médical de ces interruptions
mais ils ont peu formé au savoir dire ou
aux questions entourant l'annonce et
l'accompagnement des patients face à ce
phénomène des initiatives locales que je
salue ont vu le jour pour accompagner
les femmes et favoriser l'information à
titre d'exemple dans mon département de
la Haute-Garonne l'école des parents et
des éducateurs une association a créé un
livret un livret qui comporte notamment
les coordonnées des personnes à
contacter en cas de besoin psychologue
référent associations spécialisée groupe
de parole etc le législateur se saisit
aujourd'hui de ce sujet qui nécessite à
mon sens pas forcément un cadre
contraignant mais qui devrait faire
partie de la déontologie des
professionnels médicaux néanmoins je me
réjouis que des avancées puissent enfin
voir le jour sur ce sujet encore trop
tabou et invisibilisé il est désormais
indispensable d'accompagner ces
situations dans une approche global
holistique de la santé de la femme ainsi
dans son article premier a la
proposition de loi crée le parcours qui
a été judicieusement rebaptisé
interruption spontanée de grossesse par
Monsieur le report rapporteur que je
m'en RCI ce parcours sera mise en place
par les ARS et associera médecin
sage-femme psychologue dans le but de
développer la formation des
professionnels d'améliorer l'orientation
des femmes et de faciliter leur accès
ensuite psychologique dans cet objectif
de faciliter le suivi nous avons déposé
un amendement qui permettrait aux
sages-femmes de traiter et d'administrer
les médicaments nécessaires à une USG et
ainsi de prendre en charge de manière
globale les femmes face à une fausse
couche l'article premier B supprime le
dé de carence applicable aux arrêts
maladie pour les associer les assurés
pardon du régime général et assimilé
pour les agents publics et pour les
assurer des régimes spéciaux je salue là
aussi le travail du rapporteur qui a
élargi cette suppression de délai de
carence au travailleur indépendant
rejoindre à son souhait de le voir dans
un souci d'égalité entre les femmes quel
que soit leur statut cette mesure madame
la ministre appliquée au non salariés
agricole mais nous pouvons aller plus
loin et avec le groupe serre comme dans
le groupe geste nous proposons de mettre
en place un congé spécial de 3 jours
droit du travail pour les femmes qui
sont ainsi confrontées à cette
interruption de grossesse si certaines
femmes choisiront de ne pas y avoir
droit par peur peut-être d'être
discriminé sur leur lieu de travail ce
congé créé ainsi un droit nouveau pour
les femmes en leur laissant le choix le
choix est notamment celui de ne pas
dépendre de leur médecin pour bénéficier
d'un temps de récupération nécessaire
enfin la présente proposition de loi en
tant favorisé l'accompagnement
psychologique des couples concernés et
le dispositif donc permet de dresser les
parties les patientes
à travers le parcours mon parcours psy
si nous partageons l'ambition de cette
mesure je note simplement cependant
qu'elle risque d'avoir une portée
limitée puisque vous savez la
psychiatrie reste j'allais dire le
parent pauvre de la médecine en France
et les consultations en ambulatoire dans
le cadre dispositif monde parcours psy
mise en place depuis plus d'un anifices
et en 2022 qu'à 76000 patientes nous le
savons ce dispositif a été très mal
accueilli par la profession des
psychologues et moins de 10% des
psychologues en exercice libéral
antiadori adhéré ce nombre est très
insuffisant au regard des besoins
d'identifier aussi je me permets
d'interpeller le gouvernement sur la
nécessité de retravailler ce dispositif
en concertation avec les psychologues
afin de le rendre pleinement
opérationnel le Groupe sert profondément
engagé dans la protection de la santé
des femmes mentales comme physique
partage donc la volonté d'accompagner
davantage les femmes confrontées à une
interruption spontanée de grossesse
ainsi que leur partenaire et soutiendra
donc cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie maintenant la parole
est alors on se Cohen pour le
recommuniste républicain citoyen
écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à mon tour à remercier la
députée Sandrine Jossot à l'origine de
cette proposition de loi visant
l'accompagnement des coupes confrontés à
une fausse couche et à remercier notre
rapporteur Martin lévrier cette
initiative parlementaire permet de lever
un tabou autour des fausses couches
vécues chaque année par 200000 femmes
dans notre pays et concerne près de 15%
des grossesses en disant à nouveau
qu'une femme sur dix est confrontée à
une interruption spontanée de grossesse
on permet à ces femmes de sortir du
sentiment d'isolement cette première
étape doit accompagner d'une meilleure
information et d'un véritable
accompagnement des femmes et de leur
conjoint comme le propose le texte nous
souscrivons par conséquent à
l'instauration d'un parcours par les
agences nationales de santé qui associe
les professionnels médicaux et les
psychologues hospitaliers libéraux dans
le cadre d'une approche
pluridisciplinaire pour mieux
accompagner les femmes et leurs
partenaires il semble opportun de
développer la formation des
professionnelle médicaux sur les
conséquences psychologiques des
interruptions spontanées de grossesse et
d'améliorer le suivi médical de ces
femmes nous regrettons cependant de
devoir attendre septembre 2024 pour que
ce parcours soit appliqué de la même
manière nous espérons que la suppression
du délai de carence qui est une très
bonne chose entre en application bien
avant le premier janvier 2024 je
soulignerai au passage que la
modification de la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat qui a étendu
aux travailleurs indépendants la levée
du lever de carence est également une
mesure très positive enfin sur le cœur
du dispositif qui concerne
l'accompagnement psychologique des
patientes et de leur partenaire nous
avons de sérieux doutes sur la capacité
du dispositif mon parcours psy à
répondre à ses enjeux en effet un an
après son lancement malgré l'opposition
de la profession il apparaît que le
bilan est plus que mitigé considérant
que ce dispositif n'est ni adapté aux
réalités du métier ni aux besoins des
patientes et des patients seuls 7 des
psychologues se sont conventionnés pour
s'inscrire sur la plateforme d'accès
toutes et tous dénonce une tarification
rabais de cette prestation une mise sous
tutelle médicale dans un contexte où
l'accès direct et favorisé un nombre de
séances réduit et prédéterminé à
l'inverse même d'une approche
thérapeutique de même se pose la
question du devenir et de la prise en
charge des patientes et des patients
au-delà de ces 8 séances notamment pour
les plus modestes très fortement
mobilisés depuis plus de deux ans contre
mon parcours psy les psychologues
dénoncent un mépris total envers leur
profession avec une forme d'ubérisation
des soins je rappelle que notre groupe
le groupe CRCE avait voté contre
l'article créant ce dispositif au plfs
2022 cette vision comptable de la prise
en charge de la santé mentale s'oppose à
la fois à la réalité de la prise en
charge globale des patientes et des
patients mais également à la situation
économique les Françaises et des
Français dont je veux le rappeler ici
près de 3 millions ne disposent pas de
complémentaires santé ni d'ailleurs
d'aide pour une complémentaire santé
madame la ministre un rapport vient
d'être remis notamment à Franck Bellier
délégué ministériel à la santé mentale
un audit est en cours dans le cadre du
Printemps de l'évaluation menée par les
députés Petavy et darréville pouvez-vous
me dire dans quelle mesure le
gouvernement tiendra compte des
critiques qui sont émises sur ce
dispositif non seulement en tenir compte
mais repenser cette politique à l'égard
des psychologues cela étant nous avons
conscience que cette proposition de loi
est un premier pas que nous soutenons et
je profite de l'occasion qui m'est
donnée par cette intervention pour
souligner qu'il est en même temps
urgent de revoir la rémunération des
personnels de santé et notamment mais
sage-femmes auxquels on confère à juste
titre de nouvelles prérogatives mais
sans reconnaissance financière en
conclusion le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste votre a
en faveur de la proposition de loi et
j'espère madame la ministre que les
remarques que j'ai faites qui sont
critiques pourront être suivis de
réponse positives je vous remercie par
avance merci et en fin d'année
intervenant de Brigitte de Vesin pour 8
minutes et pour le groupe Union
centriste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales mes chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur vous l'avez dit 200000 femmes
sont concernées chaque année par une
interruption spontanée de grossesse dans
notre pays c'est un chiffre important
une grossesse sur 4 se termine en
moyenne par une fausse couche c'est un
taux élevé mais cet événement violent
n'est pas vécu de la même manière par
toutes les femmes qui sont confrontées
certaines le surmontent lorsque d'autres
le subissent comme un drame et son
profondément affectés dans la durée
l'éducation à la santé et
l'accompagnement des coupes jouent un
grand rôle dans la perception qu'on les
femmes de leur fausse couche et dans
leur potentiel séquelles psychologique
chers collègues résistant à la tentation
de catégoriser toutes ces femmes
courageuses comme des victimes regardons
les plus tôt comme des patientes et
donnons-leur les moyens de rebondir je
remercie à ce titre notre collègue
député Sandrine Josso d'avoir mis à
l'agenda politique le sujet de
l'accompagnement des couples et
singulièrement celui des femmes
confrontées à une interruption spontanée
de grossesse sa proposition de loi va
dans le bon sens elle facilite
grandement l'accès des patientes un
suivi psychologique et améliore leur
suivi médical à l'Assemblée le
gouvernement madame la ministre
utilement amendé le texte en étendant
aux femmes confrontées une fausse couche
le bénéfice d'indemnités journalières
sans délai de carence pendant toute la
durée de leur arrêt maladie je salue
également le travail de la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat et en
particulier celui du rapporteur Martin
lévrier qui a notamment permis de
renforcer l'information des coupes sur
l'interruption spontanée de grossesse et
les dispositifs d'accompagnement
disponibles
l'information et l'éducation sont en
effet la clé d'une approche apaisée du
phénomène de la fausse couche très
souvent naturelle et normal dans la vie
d'une femme bien que toujours difficile
chers collègues je l'ai dit ce texte va
dans le bon sens ainsi le groupe Union
centriste il est donc favorable mais
nous aurions souhaité pouvoir prendre
madame la ministre plus de hauteur sur
la problématique du parcours de santé
des femmes enceintes et en particulier
des femmes confrontées à une
intervention spontanée de grossesse dans
notre pays il eut été souhaitable en
effet que ce texte s'articule avec la
proposition de loi sur l'accès aux soins
adaptés en CMP le 6 avril dernier dans
certains territoires nous manquons
cruellement de gynécologues
obstétriciens pourtant sage-femme est
infirmière en pratique avancée demeure
largement écartés de l'administration de
soins et notamment de l'administration
des médicaments aux femmes concernées
par une fausse couche cette situation
paradoxale contrainte de nombreuses
femmes en moins de ont besoin de soins à
se rendre aux urgences
la croissant d'autant la durée de leur
prise en salle charge pardon et son cou
pour la société
mes chers collègues apprenons à faire
confiance aux professionnels de santé
apprenons également faire confiance aux
infirmiers en pratique avancées qui
mériteraient d'être plus impliquée dans
le protocole d'accompagnement des
couples concernés par une fausse couche
apprenant également à faire confiance
aux sages-femmes qui suivent déjà
intégralement 40% de grossesse et sont
sans doute les mieux placés pour suivre
les personnes en détresse telle est le
sens de l'amendement que ma collègue
Annick jacquemais dont je salue le
travail à déposé devant le Sénat mais
pour pouvoir faire confiance il faut
aussi en être digne rendons-nous digne
de la confiance des professionnels de
santé en ouvrant le débat sur la
situation matérielle et économique des
structures et du monde médical dans
notre pays
force est de constater que cette
question est absente du texte examiné
aujourd'hui les efforts récents ne
compensent pas les rationalisations du
passé il faut avancer et soutenir notre
système de santé
il faut sortir de l'annualité budgétaire
délétère et anticiper les changements
que l'innovation santé apporte des
avancées portées par l'industrie
pharmaceutique ou celle des dispositifs
médicaux doivent être prises en compte
pour adapter notre système au juste
moment sur le plan humain nous le savons
les pédiatres et les sages-femmes nous
ont prévenu la politique prénatale et
pose natale en France souffre de la
faible valorisation des personnels et
des difficultés de recrutement qui en
découlent et pourtant et pourtant de
belles initiatives existent par exemple
des maternités au label Ihab traitent
avec la meilleure bienveillance les
femmes et jeunes mamans je pense par
exemple à la maternité de shinen shinoni
dont les retours sont excellents et qui
attirent les futures mères bien au-delà
de sa zone géographique à l'inverse au
cours des dernières années des
établissements de santé ont été
contraints de concentrer l'activité des
sages-femmes en salle de naissance
rognan sur l'accompagnement des
patientes avant et après l'accouchement
alors parfois même vers un nombre
d'accouchements programmé très élevé et
un taux d'épisiotomie important devant
tous nos alerter de plus par manque de
moyens et de personnel les hôpitaux sont
parfois obligés de mettre en place des
programmes de sortie
ultra précoce sous 24 heures après
l'accouchement ceci est paradoxal alors
que les parents sont presque sûr
accompagnés pour préparer l'accouchement
après la sortie de l'hôpital c'est le
néant n'oublions pas enfin que 13
départements sont dépourvus de
gynécologue et 77 départements sont en
dessous de la moyenne de 2,6
gynécologues pour 100.000 femmes en âge
de consulter
chers collègues nous ne faisons pas
d'illusions l'accompagnement des
patientes pourra être complet que si
nous y mettons les moyens en
revalorisant notamment la filière des
sages-femmes tout en les impliquant
davantage dans les protocoles de soins
nous devons reconnaître rémunérer à
juste titre ces valeurs ces
professionnels de santé qui bénéficient
d'une expérience exceptionnelle et d'une
formation qualifiante en somme c'est une
réflexion plus dense sur
l'accompagnement et la prise en charge
au sein de l'hôpital et par l'hôpital
qui est à mettre sur la table que nous
appelons de nos vœux madame la ministre
mais toutefois le texte examiné
aujourd'hui constitue une avancée
indéniable c'est pourquoi le groupe
Union centriste votera en sa faveur je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
madame la ministre
juste madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur madame la Présidente de la
Commission mesdames laissez notre
messieurs les sédator et je salue
également la députée Sandrine Josso qui
n'avait pas vu tout à l'heure je vous
remercie pour l'ensemble de vos
interventions et je me réjouis d'ores et
déjà du caractère vraiment trans
partisan des différentes interventions
qui ont été les vôtres et je pense que
le sujet effectivement
est vraiment fondamental pour les droits
des femmes pour la santé des femmes de
toutes les femmes quel que soit leur
statut et c'est un enrichissement
justement du texte que permet de pouvoir
concerner toutes les femmes et puis
aussi bien sûr cet accompagnement des
couples à un moment parfois difficile
parfois douloureux de leur vie et aussi
une mesure de bien traitance puisque en
fait nous pourrons dès le premier jour
Inde donc les femmes qui subissent des
fausses couches ou des interruptions
spontanées de grossesse donc merci pour
de toutes vos interventions et
continuons nos travaux de manière aussi
transpartie sale je vous remercie merci
madame la ministre je vais suspendre la
séance je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord pour ne pas commencer l'examen
des articles à 12h55 et la séance sera
donc reprise à 14h30 pour la suite
d'examen de cette proposition de loi
[Musique]